je vous propose maintenant un nouveau
rendez-vous dans cette émission chaque
semaine chaque jeudi pour être précis on
va décortiquer les propositions des
candidats sur un thème précis dans ce
sens public c'est simple pour la
présidentielle demandez le programme
l'hôpital le pouvoir d'achat
l'immigration les retraites la
décentralisation chaque jeudi donc on
vous propose un grand thème on commence
par là fiscalité et les propositions des
candidats et les candidates en matière
de droit de succession l'héritage la
transmission du patrimoine c'est un vrai
marqueur politique Fabien Ecker c'est un
sujet sensible qui s'invite dans la
campagne présidentielle l'héritage
actuellement un parent peut donner
100000 euros à son enfant tous les 15
ans sans être taxé à droite on veut
assouplir les règles et réduire ce délai
nous serons aussi aux côtés des familles
qui veulent pouvoir transmettre sans
être surtaxé les fruits d'une vie à
leurs enfants
Valérie Pécresse promet de défiscaliser
les dons de 100000 euros tous les 6 ans
pour les parents comme pour les
grands-parents à l'extrême droite aussi
on veut alléger la fiscalité sur des
successions Éric Zemmour propose même de
la supprimer pour la transmission des
entreprises familiales quand Marine Le
mais l'accent sur les biens immobiliers
aujourd'hui taxé au-delà de 200000 euros
l'immobilier c'est l'enracinement c'est
ce qui fait que les Français
servent d'un
patrimote enraciné dans leur pays donc
je pense qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
de droit de succession jusqu'à 300000
euros alors que depuis un an plusieurs
rapports d'économistes appellent à une
réforme de l'héritage pour le rendre
plus juste à gauche on veut accéder
davantage les plus au patrimoine au-delà
de 2 millions d'euros chez Anne Hidalgo
pour 8 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales pas encore de propositions
détaillées pour l'écologie Yannick Jadot
quant à Jean-Luc Mélenchon il veut
plafonner l'héritage au-delà de 12
millions je prends tout je répète
au-delà de 12 millions écoutez-moi bien
les gens si vous n'avez pas 12 millions
d'héritages de prévu vous ne risquez
rien avec moi pas encore candidat
déclaré Emmanuel Macron a quant à lui
laissé entendre qu'il pourrait baisser
la fiscalité sur l'héritage dans les
colonnes du Parisien il y a un sujet sur
ce que j'appellerai la transmission
populaire c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on n'est
pas sur des montants exorbitants je ne
fais pas partie de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut augmenter les droits de
succession à tout va au contraire il
faut plutôt accompagner les gens pour
les aider transmettre les patrimoine
modestes en France 60% du patrimoine des
particuliers provient aujourd'hui de
l'héritage contre seulement 35% dans les
années 70 selon le Conseil d'analyser
demandez le programme consacré à la
fiscalité du patrimoine bonsoir Florence
Portelli bienvenue vous êtes
porte-parole de Valérie Pécresse
vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France et mère de Taverny Laurent
Saint-Martin bonsoir la République en
marche du Val-de-Marne rapporteur
général de la commission des finances
David Guiraud bonsoir porte-parole
jeunesse de la France insoumise
bienvenue à vous aussi on a en vision
conférence en duplex avec nous Xavier
Timbaud qui est économiste directeur de
l'Observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques bonsoir bienvenue à vous et
pas évidemment qui est resté à mes côtés
je vous propose de présenter
l'une et les autres
vos propositions en matière de fiscalité
du patrimoine Valérie Pécresse elle
entend faciliter les donations et
alléger la fiscalité sur les successions
Florence Portelli oui parce qu'il y a
deux choses il y a des successions et de
nations et d'ores et déjà sur des
donations elle propose de que les cent
gros défiscalisé soit possiblement pas
tous les 15 ans mais tous les 6 ans et
je vous entendais dire en fait parler de
filiation directe mais ça concernerait
aussi les neveux et nièces enfin on
irait beaucoup plus loin parce qu'en
fait aujourd'hui pour les filles
l'affiliation indirecte beaucoup plus
cher
mais surtout pour les successions c'est
la plus taxer ensemble au niveau des
sections je crois qu'on est aux
alentours de 55 à 60% ce qui est énorme
on va sûrement y revenir pendant
l'émission après il aura d'autres
mesures se concernant et succession elle
joue pas avec des donations mais là
c'est à des annoncera je peux pas encore
spoiler ces annonces ça va les annoncer
bientôt mais je suis pas autorisée à les
révéler déjà David Giraud vous êtes on
peut le dire à l'opposé puisque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et il dit au-dessus de 12
millions on l'a entendu je prends tout
mais d'ailleurs ça concerne combien de
personnes ça au-dessus de 12 millions
0,1% c'est pas grand monde c'est pas
grand monde mais déjà c'est symbolique
non mais non c'est pas symbolique ça
rapporte 10 milliards d'euros ah oui
c'est 10 milliards d'euros là il
permettront de ramener
apporter aux jeunes de ce pays 1000
euros par mois voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on finance cette mesure je dis ça
parce que quand on parle de patrimoine
on oublie quand même souvent une
catégorie de la population très
importante c'est ceux qui n'ont rien à
donner à leurs enfants ou si peu et donc
la question aujourd'hui c'est comment
notamment pour nos jeunes on fait en
sorte que ces jeunes qui n'ont pas de
patrimoine et qui en sont pertinemment
conscients n'est pas peur de tomber dans
le gouffre et souvent face le choix de
faire des études très rapidement ou
d'aller le plus vite dans le travail
parce que eh ben ils ont rien sinon
s'ils ne commencent pas épargner assez
tôt etc c'est ça c'est cette peur de
l'avenir qu'on essaye de d'enlever aux
gens et pour ça il faut faire un choix
il faut effectivement dire que voilà
au-dessus de 12 millions d'euros
personne ne meurt de ne hériter que 12
millions d'euros et ben oui
effectivement on prend tout pour leur
donner aux jeunes générations parce
qu'on n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'on a
un système démoc de méritocratique mais
c'est pas vrai on n'est pas un système
méritocratique aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes dans les plus riches c'est
notamment parce que vous avez hérité
c'est pas vrai qu'il y a des gens comme
ça qui sortent de nulle part avec aucun
héritage et qui arrive à devenir dans le
dans les 1% ou les
extrêmement rare mais regardez
donnez-moi des noms vous allez voir la
plupart des gens sont des héritiers
directs de plusieurs millions d'euros en
termes de fortune c'est ça qui se passe
dans le pays alors le succès story la
success story etc ça n'existe que très
peu ça peut arriver mais c'est très
marginal par rapport à la réalité que
l'héritage aujourd'hui conditionne la
richesse et d'ailleurs à tel point qu'on
a fait un bon de 50 ans en arrière de 50
ans en arrière c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui la part de l'héritage dans
dans le revenu total du pays patrimoine
des Français c'est 600% du revenu
national l'héritage il y a 50 ans
c'était 300% ça à doubler et ça doublé
pour les plus riches pas pour le alors
les gens qui donnent 60 et je donne la
parole à Laurence à Martin 50% des
français hériteront de moins de 70 000
euros 10% des Français hériteront de
500.000 euros 1% des Français hériteront
de plus de 4 millions 200000 euros c'est
le Conseil d'Analyse économiques qui
donnent ces chiffres Laurent
Saint-Martin peut-être un mot de
réaction à cette proposition un peu choc
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et puis ensuite on
va parler de des propositions de la
majorité présidentielle puisque le
président de la République n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat non
d'abord le constat chiffré il est juste
le fait qu'il y ait un millième qui soit
au-dessus de 12 ou 13 millions d'euros
il est il est correct effectivement 1% à
plus de 4 millions d'euros ce qui est
juste aussi c'est que en 50 ans on a
largement augmenté la part d'héritage
dans notre pays patrimonialement parlant
mais aussi on l'a bien concentré sur les
plus hauts patrimoines ça c'est très
juste aussi la question c'est comment
est-ce que de cette inéquité qui s'est
créée au fur et à mesure des décennies
on peut le corriger de façon lisible de
façon juste et aussi en prenant en
compte l'évolution de la société
notamment en mettant fin à la seule
filiation directe mais aussi en prenant
en compte l'ensemble de donations sur
des nouvelles solidarités qui ne sont
pas uniquement les solidarités
familiales parce que pas forcément à
plat non je suis pas favorable de
remettre un système à plat mais par
contre remettre lisibilité plus d'équité
plus de compréhension et surtout et à
mon avis c'est ça la clé d'une réforme
pertinente c'est remettre le
bénéficiaire au centre ce qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas le cas c'est à
dire le considérer que la fiscalité de
votre héritage elle doit avoir lieu non
pas une fois tous les 15 ou 6 ans en
fonction de ce que vous proposez mais
tout au long de la vie mais si je lis
Emmanuel Macron dans l'interview qu'il a
donné au Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
il y a pas eu seulement cette petite
phrase et pour les Français n'ont
vaccinés je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut augmenter les
droits de succession à tout va au
contraire nous sommes une nation de
paysans dans notre psychologie
collective ce qui est une force nous
avons cela dans un autre ADN et donc la
transmission est importante pour vous en
lisant ça je me dis bon bah
il se positionne au humidite pour le
statu quo en fait dans la République
Émilie pour la non augmentation des
impôts d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait depuis 5
ans les ABC de 50 milliards d'euros je
rappelle quand même que en 5 ans on a
annulé tous les chocs fiscaux qui
s'étaient passés comme Madame Pécresse
était ministre du Budget à l'avait
augmenté les impôts sauf François
Hollande les impôts avait augmenté nous
on a effectivement réduit pour la
première fois on a réduit pour la
première fois de 52 milliards d'euros
l'ensemble les impôts et pour les
ménages et pour les entreprises on a
enfin baissé les impôts dans ce pays on
est revenu au niveau de 2010 donc c'est
sûr qu'on va pas on va pas se changer
braquer nous on fait pas du zigzag
fiscal donc on va continuer à baisser
les impôts et des Français et des
entreprises donc là dessus le président
de la République il est très clair dans
ses ambitions comment est-ce qu'on
repense la fiscalité des transmissions
sans augmenter les impôts c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure en mettant
peut-être plus d'équité c'est-à-dire
soit en modifiant les abattements c'est
à dire en considérant que on peut
bénéficier de l'abattement de façon plus
importante mais tout au long de la vie
c'est-à-dire sans forcément avoir un
rappel fiscal parce que vous savez
l'optimisation de vous parler de
beaucoup patrimoine ça m'a permis juste
là on se perd un peu dans les dans des
notions c'est une question de
philosophie est-ce qu'on redistribue
plus ou pas et est-ce qu'on considère
que l'impôt sur la succession est un
moyen est un levier pour mieux
redistribuer la Russie c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui c'est sûr qu'on redistribue
beaucoup moins par la succession que par
le travail aujourd'hui c'est indéniable
on peut redistribuer davantage par la
succession c'est ce que je disais
le plus est droit de succession et en
même temps la part de l'héritage prend
de plus en plus de place dans le
patrimoine des Français expliquez-moi ça
bah il y a plusieurs phénomènes le
premier c'est que il y a eu une
augmentation des patrimoines qui est
très importante c'est lié
d'un côté à l'élévation du niveau de vie
aux inégalités de revenus et puis ces
inégalités de revenus en fait
s'amplifier parce que ceux qui ont du
patrimoine c'est ce qui est pas ça c'est
le premier point et vous sortir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et c'était
encore vrai dans les années 70 ben il y
avait eu la remise à zéro de la deuxième
guerre mondiale et plus la période
d'inflation qui avait un peu empêché les
patrimoines de s'accumuler c'est pas le
cas en 2020 aujourd'hui 50 ans après les
années 70 là il y a de ce côté-là oui
une explosion des patrimoines et donc un
poids dans dans l'héritage et cette
transmission des inégalités qui est
quand même qui est qui est par rapport à
notre vision de la méritocratie quelque
chose de très difficile à accepter d'un
côté effectivement les Français sont
très attendus attachés au patrimoine et
à la transmission mais on est aussi très
attaché à la méritocratie et là il
contradiction donc on peut pas juste
dire les Français préfèrent ça parce que
parce que ils aiment aussi l'égalité des
Français et là de ce point de vue là
l'héritage pose une question alors on se
dit mais alors comme on est quand même
celui qui taxe le plus ça devrait ça
devrait empêcher cette accumulation et
ses héritages mais en fait on est celui
qui texte le plus mais on taxe pas
beaucoup et on taxe de moins en moins la
la fiscalité de l'héritage et des
successions elle est vraiment
caractérisée par une réduction de
l'assiette de plus en plus d'exonération
la possibilité de donation anticipée
même si ça a été compliqué et plutôt une
baisse des taux est plutôt une baisse
des taux en ligne directe en tout cas
bon la ligne indirecte en France est une
quelque chose de effectivement assez
problématique et assez injuste et pas du
tout adapté aux formes modernes des
relations entre les gens et de leur
conception à eux de la famille en fait
c'est là où vraiment ça se ça ça heurte
la réalité mais voilà on taxe peu et ça
explique pourquoi beaucoup de patrimoine
sont très très peu taxés
ceux qui sont taxés c'est ce en fait qui
sont plutôt à la fin du du dernier des
cils sans être les très très riche parce
que effectivement cela peuvent
bénéficier de dispositifs d'exemption de
niche fiscales assez importantes mais si
on si on accepte une toute petite
minorité de français
disons riches sans être très riche ben
presque personne ne paye de droits de
succession Laetitia vous êtes intéressé
à la à la symbolique à l'imaginaire
collectif autour de de l'impôt et les
sur les sucs qui sont oui parce que là
vous voyez il vient de dire riche sans
être trop riche qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire je me suis dit ok alors déjà avant
de de j'ai mis un petit peu ma casquette
de naïve mais quand même les premières
la première question qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est combien de français sont
concernés par la succession c'est-à-dire
ont quelque chose à donner ou quelque
chose à recevoir peut-être que vous avez
les chiffres en pourcentage parce qu'il
existe quand même il me semble un grand
nombre de Français qui n'ont ni à donner
ni à recevoir je disais tout à l'heure
50% des français hériteront de moins de
70 000 euros dont une partie importante
c'est pour ça que je dis bon et donc
si de l'électorat parce que je pense
bien sûr parce que nous sommes à 3 mois
du premier tour de
vous
et ensuite je me suis dit est-ce que en
fonction
juste la situation
socioprofessionnelle financière on est
pour ou contre les droits de succession
par exemple quand on est locataire ou
propriétaire quand on est en bas de
l'échelle sociale quand on a plutôt et
finalement non c'est à dire qu'en terme
d'image c'est vraiment très net l'impôt
sur la fortune qui revient aussi à
finalement taxé le patrimoine et
conspuer d'une certaine manière je sais
qu'il y a des exceptions et
80% des Français est vraiment toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion sont unanimes 80% des
Français trouvent illégitimes les droits
de succession encore une fois quel que
soit leur situation pourquoi parce que
cet axe est perçu finalement comme une
double imposition c'est à dire que par
exemple qu'on a une maison on paye des
impôts tout au long de sa vie et puis
ensuite une fois que la personne décède
il faut repayer et c'est vrai que c'est
une injustice qui est vraiment perçue
comme telle en tout cas par 80% de
d'ailleurs électorale résultats impôt
sur la mort souvent voilà
ça veut dire j'ai trimé toute ma vie
mais il y a pas que ça même une maison
il y a une chanson de Bénabar comme ça
je sais pas si vous la connaissez qui
est très émouvante qui raconte justement
toutes les fratries tous les gens qui
ont grandi dans la maison
il explique finalement au bout d'un
moment il y a un nouveau coup qui arrive
mais il y a toujours ses fantômes on a
tous mon madeleine de Proust que parfois
ça passe par des biens immobiliers c'est
pas forcément une richesse comme on
entend avec des valeurs mobilières ou
avec
des gens qui auraient un mode de vie
très riche parfois c'est tout simplement
un patrimoine immobilier qui raconte une
histoire et c'est vrai qu'en plus tout à
l'heure j'écoutais votre excellent
intervenant mais il y a une des raisons
aussi pour lesquelles l'héritage a pris
de la valeur pour certains c'est la
hausse des du de l'immobilier de la
valeur immobilière donc ça aussi ça a
joué mais il y a des gens moi je me suis
amusé bêtement à faire une simulation il
y a un très bon site de l'État service
public qui vous permet de faire des
simulations selon votre situation pour
savoir combien vous allez payer en cas
d'héritage donc j'ai pris un bien à
500.000 euros bon pièce moyenne sup qui
peut se payer avec un lourd crédit
parfois un pardon mais sur un crédit de
25 ans vous pouvez parfois vous payer
une maison à 500000 € sans être non plus
côté à la Bourse quoi et j'ai pris
l'exemple d'une nièce qui hérite parce
que il y a pas d'enfants et
l'affiliation directe filiation directe
je vous la fait courte mon arrivée à peu
près à 70000 euros à peu près de taxes
d'affiliation indirecte la nièce elle
est arrivée à plus de 200000 euros
donc c'est vrai que la Lancia n'a pas
grand chose si elle est salaire moyen
elle pourra pas se racheter peut-être la
maison laquelle elle est très attachée
parce que c'était presque l'enfant
adoptif de la tente ou du de l'oncle qui
n'a pas eu d'enfants donc c'est vrai que
tout à l'heure le système de
l'affiliation directe il est plus adapté
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'était un des sujets prépondérants dans
les cahiers de doléances vous savez au
moment du National donc c'est vraiment
un sujet que ce sont approprié les
Français et donc très délicat pour
n'importe qui se présente à l'élection
présidentielle qui me font sourire déjà
il y a un débat entre libéraux pour
savoir qui a baissé le plus d'impôts
votre débat c'est de savoir qu'il y a le
plus baissé les impôts des riches parce
que il y a un moment faut arrêter de se
mentir la moitié des français payent pas
par exemple l'impôt sur le revenu
d'accord donc quand vous baissez l'impôt
sur le revenu vous baissez vous vous ça
profite pas ou 50% des français les plus
pauvres de ce pays 50% je parle d'un
Français sur deux là par contre la
cotation c'est pour cette discussion
tous ceux qui la paye oui mais vous avez
les 15% les plus pauvres qui la paye pas
non voilà ça leur revient pas non plus
dans les poches alors il y a tout un
débat c'est vrai il y a une suppression
alors de trouver quelque chose de
déréglé quand sous le quinquennat Macron
les 1% les plus pauvres et perdent de
l'argent tandis que 1% les plus riches
ils gagnent de l'argent sous le
quinquennat vous trouvez pas qu'il y a
quelque chose qui va pas moi je trouve
qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas et
maintenant sur la question des de du
patrimoine de l'héritage etc encore une
fois faut pas avoir de discussion
théoriques quoi aujourd'hui en France
les 1% les plus riches du pays ils
détiennent 25% du patrimoine d'accord 1%
détient 25% du patrimoine total il y a
quelque chose qui est déréglé et c'est
pour ça précisément pour cette raison-là
qu'il y a des gens qui ont rien à donner
et c'est vrai que c'est un crève-cœur
pour des familles d'avoir rien à donner
de dire j'ai rien à lui léguer voilà
j'ai rien à lui donner
après mais si ils ont rien à donner
c'est à nous en tant que société de leur
donner aux gamins voilà c'est pour ça
que quand on dit on prend au
0,1%, ça veut dire les 12 millions
d'héritage les 0,1% qui transmettent le
plus on prend cet argent effectivement
faut assumer de le prendre parce que on
peut pas donner de l'argent de nulle
part il y a un moment faut faire un
Choixpeau
les jeunes en formation
pour faire leur étude pour la dignité
à assembler de la rhétorique insoumise
dérange pas on a juste pas la même
vision des choses on peut tout à fait
lutter contre les inégalités destin et
aider les les amis les plus précaires
dans ce pays sans avoir à spolier et
sans avoir à avoir des taux
confiscatoires sur l'argent sur les sur
les hauts patrimoine ce qui mais
regardez les recettes fiscales dans ce
pays regardez quand elles augmentent
avec la croissance que l'on crée etc ce
qui m'intéresse
ce qui m'intéresse de ce que vous disiez
madame aussi c'est que finalement ce que
l'on voit ici c'est que c'est pas
vraiment un débat fiscal c'est un débat
sociétal c'est pas des BAF fiscal parce
que encore une fois la très grande
majorité des gens qui disent et qui se
disent choqués par cette fiscalité là ne
la paye pas et c'est le seul impôt où
vous avez cette contradiction de lutte
contre l'impôt que vous ne payez pas
c'est assez rare il faut le reconnaître
par quoi parce que ça touche
effectivement à l'intime ça touche au
Patos et c'est donc c'est une fiscalité
qui est sensible et c'est pour ça que le
débat est finalement plus sociétal
politique que réellement que réellement
fiscal que la réforme a eu lieu pendant
alors d'abord
c'était pas une réforme de programme
donc on n'a pas abandonné quelque chose
qu'on avait promis on n'avait pas fait
une proposition 2017 mais par contre
vous avez raison c'est pour ça que c'est
un sujet plus sensible que les autres en
fiscalité ça c'est vrai mais ça c'est
c'est de la j'allais dire ni trop de
glycérine c'est peut-être un peu fort
mais c'est une thématique difficile à
manier quoi de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique par rapport à
Marine Le Pen par exemple qui est
propositions fortes on a Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et c'est vrai que votre
proposition
elle mérite d'exister mais finalement
0,1% on prend pas non plus des gros
risques on va pas choquer les Français
en se disant vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est que même à gauche de ce qui
est politique bon on essaye de prendre
des gants parce que quand on est pour ça
non
du sondage on parle Laetitia 80% des
Français trouver
75% on a vu ce que ça a donné quand même
c'est pardon mais la fiscalité c'est une
dynamique c'est pas statique monsieur
Giraud si vous mettez des
toconfiscatoire pardon les patrimoines
et les capitaux mobiliers ils s'en vont
dans ce pays on l'a démontré en
une assiette une assiette bouge c'est
vrai vous avez raison moins dans le
capital immobilier que dans le capital
mobilier par définition mais en fait
c'est quand même tout aussi vrai que le
capital s'en va de ce pays quand vous
mettez des
propositions parce que vous dites vous
affirmez des choses mais pardon si les
gens veulent s'en aller au revoir
la maison elle va rester en France il
parle pas avec la maison sur le dos hein
donc là mais s'ils veulent s'en aller
pour échapper à l'imposition pour
échapper à la devise quand même de la
République et liberté égalité fraternité
d'accord ça compte hein quand même au
revoir mais on est en train aussi de
travailler sur des dispositifs qui
s'appelle par exemple l'impôt universel
que pratique les États-Unis d'Amérique
qui sont quand même pas un grand pays
communiste voilà qui vise à imposer les
gens même quand il partait
internationale pourquoi parce que on est
dans une société quand vous avez quand
vous allez à l'école même si vous êtes
riche c'est gratuit quand vous allez à
l'hôpital c'est gratuit parce que ça
s'appelle la solidarité c'est normal que
ça soit mais au bout d'un moment on peut
pas laisser dire que cette gratuité elle
vient de nulle part il y a une question
redistribution des richesses c'est
important
à ce que vous disiez bon déjà pour
revenir aux côtés sentimental aussi un
peu tout ça regardez la Belgique la
Belgique par exemple en taxe il y a pas
de taxe sur les successions sur les
résidences principales quand vous avez
votre résidence principale pendant 5 ans
en Italie il n'y a pas forcément un
niveau de vie extraordinaire surtout en
ce moment en fait jusqu'à un battement
de 1 million d'euros et pourtant et je
vais vous dire pourquoi alors vous allez
me dire non mais un billon mais c'est ce
qu'en Italie c'est sentimental aussi de
la famille c'est sacré le patrimoine ce
qu'on a construit pendant une vie un
labeur c'est sacré et il y a une vision
de la famille qui fait que c'est
impensable de taxer comme ça et le
patrimoine c'est même pas c'est pas une
question de favoriser des riches des
paris c'est une question d'image enfin
de de sentiment je sais pas comment ils
sont comme ça de symbolique et pour
revenir à ce que vous disiez sur les
gens qui n'ont rien à transmettre je
suis d'accord avec vous la différence
c'est que c'est sur des solutions mais
je suis d'accord avec vous c'est pas
normal qu'aujourd'hui dans un pays où
finalement tout le monde aimerait
transmettre quelque chose c'est ce qu'on
va dans le sondage et bien justement il
y a des gens qui ne s'en sortent pas
mais ça c'est un problème d'ascenseur
social et moi je crois que c'est pas
d'état de redistribuer moi je pense
qu'il faut au contraire créer la nation
éducative qu'on propose pour permettre à
chacun de s'en sortir une fois qu'il
sort de l'école une fois qu'il sort de
ses études mais c'est aussi de valoriser
les salaires c'est pour ça qu'on propose
d'augmenter de 10 % et salaire jusqu'à
2,2 fois de Smic et c'est vrai qu'on a
c'est vrai qu'on a je viens de vous le
dire
comment vous faites on peut partir sur
un débat là déjà expliqué elle trouvait
des économies mais en tous les cas en
tous les cas bah c'est pas grave on vous
expliquera trois fois si vous voulez
mais tous les cas la revalorisation des
salaires moi j'y crois profondément
parce que je pense qu'en effet c'est pas
normal que quand vous trimez toute votre
vie vous n'ayez rien à transmettre
c'est la croissance des entreprises
je reprends la main une minute avec une
nouvelle rubrique dans ce sens public en
partenariat avec
brief me c'est un briefing diffusé
chaque soir qui résume et explique
l'actualité réalité c'est diffusé par
email et sur une appli Mobile dit les 10
minutes de lecture quotidienne c'est
factuel c'est indépendant c'est sans pub
voilà je vous explique ce qu'est brucemi
si vous ne le connaissez pas le
rédacteur en chef de brief 1000 Laurent
Mauriac va me rejoindre tout de suite
bonsoir Laurent très heureux de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau posez donc un
bilan de la réforme de l'impôt sur la
fortune qui a été une des premières
réformes du quinquennat Macron elle
consistait en quoi cette réforme alors
cette réforme a été proposée par
Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne de
2017 il s'agissait de supprimer l'ISF
donc l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune et de le remplacer par l'IFI
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière alors
quelle différence entre les deux l'ISF
était un successeur de l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes instauré en 1982 par
François Mitterrand et il taxé
l'ensemble du patrimoine en revanche le
nouvel hi-fi ne porte que sur
l'immobilier et exclu les placements
financiers pour défendre cette réforme
Emmanuel Macron a mis en avant plusieurs
arguments
l'ISF ne jouait pas un rôle décisif dans
la réduction des inégalités il nuisait à
l'investissement dans les entreprises il
est obligé les actionnaires à demander
des dividendes trop importants pour
pouvoir le payer il a incité des
centaines de contribuables à s'expatrier
chaque année donc l'argument centrale
d'Emmanuel Macron était en remplaçant
l'ISF parifi on agissait pas simplement
en faveur des riches mais de l'économie
en général et donc de l'ensemble de la
population alors comment s'est passé le
vote et quels ont été les réactions
alors le vote de la réforme a eu lieu en
octobre 2017 Bruno Le Maire le ministre
de l'Économie a défendu la suppression
d'un totem je cite vieux de 35 ans le
parti les républicains a réclamé la
suppression pure et simple de l'ISF
c'est-à-dire son non remplacement par
par l'IFI mais il a majoritairement voté
en faveur de la réforme la gauche dans
son ensemble a mis l'accent sur le
creusement des inégalités que cette
réforme risquait d'engendrer et c'est
assez occasion que l'image du président
des riches a commencé à s'immiscer dans
une partie de l'opinion ça a été le
titre d'une note de blog de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en septembre 2017 et le débat
sur l'ISSF a resurgi un an plus tard
avec le mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
a demandé son rétablissement mais
Emmanuel Macron s'y refusé et voici ce
qu'il disait en janvier 2019 lors du
grand débat national organisé pour
répondre à ce mouvement
faut pas raconter des cracks c'est pas
parce qu'on remettra l'ISF comme il
était il y a un an et demi que la
situation d'un seul gilet jaune
s'améliorera ça c'est de la pipe voilà
on retrouve le langage d'Emmanuel Macron
dans ces dans ces grands débats ce qui
est intéressant avec le recul c'est
d'évaluer les effets de la réforme alors
le nombre de foyers redevables a
fortement baissé on est passé de 358
000 contribuables de l'ISF en 2017 à
133000 pour l'ifly en 2018 et les
recettes fiscales ont été divisées par 3
maintenant si on reprend les objectifs
de la réforme sur les inégalité
l'Institut des politiques publiques un
organisme indépendant a montré en
novembre que les 1% les plus riches sont
ceux qui ont le plus profité des mesures
fiscales mises en oeuvre pendant le
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron mais il y
a eu d'autres mesures et il n'est pas
possible d'isoler l'impact de la seule
réforme de l'ISF quant à l'effet sur
l'économie une mission d'évaluation a
été confiée à France stratégie un
organisme d'études qui dépend du Premier
ministre et dans un rapport publié en
octobre il conclut que cet impact est
très difficile à mesurer et il ne note
rien de significatif alors dernier point
sur l'expatriation de certains
contribuables France stratégie constate
plus de retour que de départ depuis la
réforme mais il s'agit seulement de
quelques centaines de personnes au final
il n'y a pas d'effets nets sur le plan
économique du moins pour l'instant et la
portée symbolique de cette réforme est
plus importante que son efficacité
économique merci Laurent pour toutes ces
explications à la semaine prochaine
évidemment pour représenter brief me sur
sur ce plateau Laurent Saint-Martin est
est-ce que finalement c'était la
démonstration là c'est de dire que
c'était une réforme plus symbolique que
efficace au risque de coller cette
étiquette de président des riches quand
même à Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 n'arrivée aux commandes de ce
pays avec un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire le plus important au monde
d'accord aujourd'hui le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire il est de 43,6%
de notre PIB à peu près le retour à ce
qu'il était il y a 12 ans on a créé tout
de suite un choc fiscal notamment un
choc fiscal du réinvestissement ça
passait par la transformation de l'ISF
ça passait aussi et surtout par une
autre mesure que la flat tax c'est à
dire baisser les impôts mais surtout les
rendre ISO flat sur toute la fiscalité
des revenus du capital c'est cet
ensemble de fiscalité qui a créé un
climat d'investissement dans ce pays on
peut considérer que c'est pas la
politique qu'il faut faire dans notre
pays mais enfin on a enfin rendu enfin
rendu compétitif et surtout
on va dire favorable à l'investissement
le climat et la fiscalité en France
enfin ça faisait des décennies qu'on
avait des taux qu'on fiscatoires
systématiquement notamment sur les
revenus du capital et donc le résultat
c'est lequel le résultat c'est que quand
vous avez une crise comme on l'a vécu là
depuis 18 mois bien vous avez une
capacité de rebond qui est beaucoup plus
importante qu'avant si vous avez une
capacité de réinvestissement qui est
beaucoup plus importante qu'avant vous
avez une capacité d'emploi qui est plus
importante qu'avant et vous savez c'est
pas anodin si aujourd'hui en 2022 on a
un pays avec une croissance plus forte
que nos voisins c'est pas anodin si on a
un pays qui investit davantage dans ces
entreprises qu'avant la crise c'est pas
anodin si on a un taux d'emploi
je vous explique que je vous explique
qu'on ne peut pas considérer la
fiscalité comme un enjeu purement
statique et symbolique la fiscalité ce
sont des leviers qui font bouger la
société et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre parce que supprimer l'ISF le
transformer en hi-fi faire la flat tax
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu les
Français baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés baisser les charges baisser les
impôts de production baisser de 52
milliards d'euros les prélèvements
obligatoires dans notre pays oui ça crée
un climat de consommation et
d'investissement dans un pays qu'on
n'avait jamais eu pu créer de la
croissance et de l'emploi c'est ça en
fait le message on a supprimé les SF
mais on n'a pas euh
on l'a transformé on est d'accord mais
on n'a pas on n'a pas valorisé les
riches on a aussi baissé les impôts pour
tout le monde dans ce pays
enfin un climat d'investissement
les droits de succession lequel d'après
vous peut-être qu'il y en a d'autres
d'autres mesures lequel de ces impôts
est plus efficace pour réduire ses
inégalités de patrimoine on l'a dit
qu'ils sont croissantes dans ce pays bah
écoutez bon c'est un débat un peu
compliqué la la toute cette
patrimoine juste je vais vous donner un
exemple si une réforme qui a été menée
en Suède dans lequel on a entièrement
supprimé les droits de succession et
dans lequel on a int suffit simplement
une chose qui est la taxation des
plus-values au moment du décès donc
c'est un détail un peu technique mais
qui a quand même une grande importance
en France par exemple quand vous mourrez
les plus-values que vous avez réalisés
sur vos actifs mobiliers ou immobiliers
sont réputés éteintes et donc les impôts
qui sont dus à ce titre ne seront payés
par personne et vous héritiers en hérite
à la valeur au moment de votre mort ils
sont éventuellement soumis à des droits
de succession sur cette valeur là mais
les plus-values qui ont été réalisées ne
sont pas taxées donc en Suède on a fait
une réforme dans lequel on a dit on
enlève tous les droits de succession et
on ne fait qu'une seule chose ces
contacts les plus-values réalisées donc
vous achetez un appartement à Paris en
il y a 40 ans vous avez une plus-value
aujourd'hui qui est très importante qui
peut être disons d'un million d'euros et
ben en France quand vos héritiers vont
bénéficier ce patrimoine ils vont payer
les droits de succession sur la valeur
d'appartement mais ne pas payer sur la
plus-value alors en Suède on va le payer
25% sur la plus-value et le gros
avantage de ça c'est que ça permet quand
même de rassurer beaucoup les gens parce
que la maison familiale sur laquelle il
y a pas de plus-value parce qu'elle est
à la campagne où il y a une plus-value
faible elle va donner lieu à une
taxation qui sera faible alors que cet
appart cet appartement à Paris et qui
lui a une prix énormément de valeur sera
assez fortement taxé et donc plus que de
de chercher à faire du rendement fiscal
rétablir une forme d'égalité entre les
Français ça paraît extrêmement important
alors ce qui est intéressant en Suède
c'est que cette réforme suppression des
droits de succession et simplement
taxation des plus-values a conduit à
avoir en fait un rendement qui a été
meilleur et probablement beaucoup plus
de justice et je pense que c'est vers ce
genre de choses qu'il faut aller
voilà l'immobilier est une une
composante très importante du patrimoine
les plus-values immobilières sont
souvent ce qu'on peut qualifier en
termes fiscal un enrichissement sans
cause et donc c'est c'est arrivé à le
taxer c'est assez important et assez
intéressant pour l'équité merci Xavier
Timbaud merci à tous merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat jeudi prochain
demandez le programme on va parler
énergie on va scruter les propositions
des candidats notamment l'avenir du
nucléaire